hey youtubers it's Charlie, thank you everyone that submitted questions for this weeks Arrow Flash
mid season finale Q&A
so many WTFs so we'll get through it to
a lotta questions about
who hears in Wells is and what's going
on with all over this reminder the flash
in a row are both coming back in same
week the flash will be back
January 20th air will be back the next
day on the 21st
just careful for spoilers from both the
episode if you haven't seen yet but
13 questions number one make love an ass
what was up with malcolm videotaping FEA
killing Sarah and their didn't say
anything about it
not to mention malcolm's phone is that a
fake video no it's not a fake video he
wasn't fill me in on this phone
so malcolm's pride is donning her murder
from a long distance
and then uploaded the video to his phone
he pry wasn't using his phone to film it
he just had the video on his phone
question to I will one asks
hope we get to see Roy get the spotlight
bought a row is out
and seeing world in black would be great
yes we will see both those things
Roy will very much get the spotlight
Walters away we don't know how many
episodes
exactly offers going to be gone probably
a couple at least
in present-day we might seem in
flashbacks raised gonna fill the gap
he asked them to take care fear but he
is going to take care of everything that
oliver normally does
except for that love triangle with Ray
Palmer I think was gonna pretend like
that doesn't exist
there would be pretty funny site so
Felicity
I'm going to have to stare longingly
into your eyes for the next five minutes
because
Oliver said to do all the things that he
used to do funny thing about that
Emely bit records and Colton Haynes in
real life have been seen a lot outside
the said
question number three then sort as why
would all over in rage
work together and if they didn't how to
defeat the play going to Oliver's chest
and if they did how did they know that
he wouldn't bleed to death or break his
neck during the fall
that's a good question I don't think
that they were working together buddy
buddy
but I do think the dollar had a
contingency plan one possible reason for
them working together
is because something bunny is going on
inside the legal assassins
and racial go wants to find out what it
is I don't think that's very likely
I don't think they were working together
at least not in the sense that people
think they are
they cannot buddies but I think all over
definitely had a plan going into that
fight
and I think it went down the way he
thought it was gonna go down
on it's far back in season 2 he mention
how big
racial goal was like but a big deal it
was so he knew the heap I would lose the
fight
and I don't think that the fake dating I
think he really is on the edge of death
like you just gotta sword ship through
his belly I would be surprised if it
does
for some crazy reason turn out there
working together that rage
penetrated his stomach in a very non
critical place
they did during sure like series 3 where
one character shoot another character to
make them look like they're dead
but the berliners in one of the few
places Bertone actually kill them
dearly with beatings like this there's
always something going on underneath
there's always like a side plot that we
don't know about till later
it's a bit of a bait-and-switch saying
but ill be a lot of fun whatever the
explanation is
question for at the van as we be doing a
video on Mark Hamill joining the flash
now right now up I will do some more
Robidas whenever get closer to his
episode is going to be a lot of the
roads in the back after the season
Mark Hamill said is funny thing on
Twitter went down with the ship
congratulated him for coming back
he said this time will get it right in
accord
john was a ship said well we gotta read
the first time you know who's trying to
say that
is silly as it was during the original
series it was still a very good show
I think any actor working on show should
believe in what they're doing even if
after the fact it seems a little bit
silly it is everyone getting out on the
fact they're making such a fun show
afraid you more about his character when
we get closer to that episode
it sounds like based on the man episode
that film so far
bill come sometime after episode 14 so
sometime between 14 and 20
are happening episodes exactly the flash
getting it might just get 22 are making
a full twenty three episodes
air usually gets 23 episodes which is a
lot so sometime between 14 in the finale
I don't think he's going to be the
finale questioned by Baird tougher
when all requires dying he think that
his father his mother sister
Felicity when he was being watched by
death stroke in season 2 ito plus the
the Laurel isn't the love is like
she is he wasn't pretending yes Stephen
Amell said some really important things
about
oliver's final moments on the mound he
said that his thoughts crystallized
about all those people all those things
says that all overhead a moment a
complete clarity where all these
feelings
crystallize in that moment a debt are
the moment before dat
whatever looks like dat me that when he
does come back you'll be acting
differently based on those feelings
like
moment is him just processing ok eight
this is the way I feel about all these
beings these people
namely policy being the final moment so
whether you love it or you hate it
there will be more all that's the stuff
going on in the back after the season
whenever he does come back although it's
not gonna turn into a so proper anything
like that
interesting to note though planned route
use a star on a soap opera
just like Jensen Ackles from
Supernatural I like Big John reactors
that came from soap operas
but you never think it it was funny to
watch the old footage you know they're
great
we love you Brandon question number six
John Liu ass
it that he's in the CW Post is any
indication I theorize that Merlin takes
into the latter's pit
in either turns all over into his own
killing machine with the drug are
manipulating
by some other means it also makes me
wonder if there's someone else working
with Berlin the shadows
who could take into the pit after
Aldershot in season one
like China white maybe a duty to China
white will be involved in
a present-day in some way but I think I
had something to do with the bioweapon
I don't be that Oliver's going to be
using the Lazarus Pit I don't do the
reading that story line
in the episode and promo like the video
promo we do see footsteps walking up so
clearly someone is going to find him
help nurse them back to health probably
with the combination medicine
I don't think we're gonna see green fire
lazar's pit
that's a bit of a long shot I'm had
fought my chair we saw that
I think we'll see a lot of metaphors for
his journey on the island
this is another crucible for him Stephen
Amell whenever he's talking about oliver
people getting costumes
always talks about crucibles the island
was a crucible
Hong Kong as a crucible now this
mountain is a crucible
come out on the other side as the news
that a debt in this case
much stronger the vastly more
crystallized outlook
on his hero's journey question 7 to cap
a source ass
we already saw crossover with the heroes
do you think there'll be a crossover
with the villains
as in billings teaming up for possibly
even against each other
yet will Whittlesea like up a road to
cross over with the air on the flash
eventually
I kinda consider the suicides what
episodes billing crossovers just because
you usually get a couple them in their
but I realize what you're talking about
you talking about like big villains
I think eventually yes we will
definitely see something like that
in a much bigger way this season though
just because things are kinda getting
started with the flash
I think the crossovers would just be
internal
like you deceive villains from a row
working together
and you'll see billions from the flash
working together the best example that
on a flash
is the roads when the episode is going
to be like a rogue's revenge story
that's all the promos for the next
episode are episode 10 in a flash
but whenever it comes back in the spring
it'll be a rhodes episode
Deathstroke is coming back in episode 14
but they didn't say how he might still
be in that prison he might have escaped
we have no idea the last time we saw
Captain Boomerang in a crossover
they said they stuck in in the same
Argus prison that's laid then
I'm really hoping that they actually do
something together like they break out
together
that is awesome which number eight
militia ass but was the best finale
the mid-season a row flash shield are
got them
well fun schiller amazing I think the
Aero punched me in the feels
yes I W the area was my favorite but I
think that flash has the better villain
all the midseason finale as per grade
government still finding its legs a
little bit
it took its sweet time getting to Arkham
I wish it was a dark and the whole time
I was which is an Arkham show
government bond Arkham way better into
shield
finally got in humans totally hugely
from the comics
and he's really awesome that the reason
the TV show to introduce that
even if we probably will never see the
royal family in the flash does have a
better bill and
if you like Tom Cavanagh as a villain is
a better character
then ratio goes on air right now but to
his credit
he's been in every single episode so he
is that so much more screen time to
develop that character
them at Naval has had to develop the
racial character
so might have to reassess which show has
the best going after all the seasons are
over
but the reason i picked a rose my
favorite is because they killed their
main character
they had the guts to do that on screen
even if nope big twist
he's not actually dead question number
19 yo ass but if Laura was secretly
affected by the particle accelerator
explosion
I don't think that she was but that
would be ditching .tv is closer to our
comic book version for character
we're just gonna see her get her ass
handed to her for the next couple
episodes it's not a simple
as putting a costume on in calling
yourself a superhero
best part about her journey is Stephen
Amell explain that
they're not gonna make the leap to her
being black me right away
they wouldn't do that even though she's
gonna the costume she's not going to be
very good at what she does right away
question 10 consuming fire
asks what is going on with Wells was
that his future self
interacting with his present self it
depends on which version appears in well
as you think Aaron wells is
I was i think thats a pseudonym I think
he is the future versions like the most
future version I think the simplest
explanation is the best
he is working with that other rivers
flash we saw whether or not they're the
same person remains to be seen
based on the weight the man in the
yellow suit Oct not hear some wells but
we were looking at the end of the
episode
he sounded like he was a very
intelligent percent just as intelligent
as here some wells
I think what they did was a big actors
in Wells wasn't surprised by anything
I would assume that it's a future
version of him and there's been some
sort of messing with the time line
that's caused him to be stuck in the
past
it's a little confusing but I'm lose
because if he already got it at the same
person appears most is the man yellow
in there just two different versions
have him from different times why is he
stuck in the past
that being said yes I do think we'll see
two different versions
up the reverse flash it's not gonna be
just professor zoom
will also see the hundreds of them on
Zoom I think eddie Van
is the progenitor that line I think
that's why the river slotched
the man in the yellow suit did not kill
em because he recognized that
a lot of people are saying that the man
in yellow by the future version A Eddie
but I don't think that he is that smart
when the really important things to
remember when jerry crafting is the idea
internal consistency purses continuity
hundreds of them on was a great detected
but he was not a great scientist
it is still possible that he is involved
so i think is going on
is that here's in Wells is a very very
far future version
other verse flash and the man in the
lawsuit is somewhere in between
85 on and hear some wells in the time
line like yours in Wells is
eighties grants under great-great-great
grandson the medically I think it just
looks better on the page from a story
perspective when everyone is
that closely connected it gives new
meaning to the idea of the flash family
which number eleven look any ass on the
newspaper
it says Wintec Queen Inc merger complete
but right now cleaning
doesn't exist anymore so yeah everyone
thinks this is the big a restraining it
actually is
it actually means nothing for the show
it's just something internally on a
flashed
that denotes whether or not the future
has changed the newspapers the important
thing
is the hero Batman crossover is an
important for the show's it is something
funny that the producers did it was
never meant to imply any future plot
line they were going to do
question for 12 do you think that any
the future flashes bob is it in help
bury
like Bali her part yes I totally think
that's gonna happen
probably not right away their planet
like season to season 3
I think the closest will see to that
Essenes Wally West shows up
and becomes another version the flash I
think that would be more a fire storm
situation to where they're not in
every single episode but they are like
three or four per season
but I'm really hoping they do is Placid
two worlds in accidentally ends up on
her two or something like that in resin
to Jay Garrick
I think they will do a story like that
at some point thank you so much everyone
for leaving questions does it have fun
to do
and leave your request for future bonus
the others are doing burns be as next
week
and be sure to subscribe to get
everything be just fine to me for the
first time
big news from this said rod email has
been filming a ton up flash
he posted this picture really recently
up in standing in a field with that 3
firestorm lights on
it's just the nucleus of an atom it's a
firestorm thing from the character in
the comics
I think that means that we'll see him in
a costume by the end of the season
would be just amazing there was also a
picture that Stephen Amell posted up him
on the set %uh a row he had a wig on
Stephen male had awake
so could it has been him visiting or
oliver whenever he comes back
could have long hair I think it was
during a flashback scene no
distant things to look for to whatever
the show first comes back so
we're going to get the roads on the
flash double back have to call them he
we ever gonna team up
in on a row we're gonna see Black Canary
get her costume
I have no idea when ripon MERS gonna
first put on the Anacostia
I can take a lot longer for that one
since Tuesday when days are using my
flash
a road is I'll try to post on my bones
beers on those days but is really going
on for a couple weeks so it's like to be
a long
right now if you're on your mobile phone
or on your tablet there's newt links you
can click on
appear I think it's actually over here
at the same as the links over here
but click here for my top 5 reach UGL
stories from the comics
and click here for all my Aero plaster
now I videos thank you so much washing
clothes off
i buy I'll see you guys tonight
up